Hello.
My name is Kunal, and in this course,
we will answer one big question Android
developers answer all the time, and
that question is,
how do you use blank in Android?
For instance, how do you use
radio buttons, or grids, or maps?
And a whole bunch of different
components that
are available in Android.
Now if you think about it, developers
encountered this question all the time.
And in response what they will do,
is that they will conduct a search on
the internet,
read something like a blog or
some stack overflow page on how
you do something in Android.
And then they will try
that in their app.
We will follow a similar
approach in this course.
To be successful, you will need
the basics of Android programming.
We took those in the Android for
beginners course.
This is where, among other things,
we made the happy birthday app and
the Just Java app.
You may also recall
that in the Android For
Beginners course, we learned
about buttons and check boxes.
In this course, we will work with toggle
buttons, radio buttons, spinners, and
much more.
Here is how this course
is going to work.
For each of these interface elements
that you see on the screen here,
we found the best resource on
the Internet that teaches you
how to use them in your app.
So for toggle buttons,
we will link you to a tutorial.
For radio buttons,
we'll do the same thing.
And trust us, these links are good.
We know that because we've
used them ourselves.
Here's what we want you to do.
At the end of this video,
you will see a tutorial on how to
use toggle buttons in Android.
Follow the instructions
in that tutorial, and
learn how to implement toggle buttons
in an app that you build from scratch.
Once you're done with that, move on to
the tutorial for radio buttons and so
on so forth.
Also, each one of these links that
you're about to see will take you about
30 to 60 minutes to learn.
Once you do a few of these,
you will have mastered the process
experienced Android developers
follow every single day.
Let's begin.